[Music]
all right guys I know this isn't apply
to us anymore because our job is our
jobs are hysterically fun and easy but
other people have real jobs so it sucks
right and
um
I thought we'd help people out this is a
little little quick little video of from
the BBC how to tell if you're being
bullied at work
so dreading shut up
hey hey man
all right
[Music]
I was planning all the time we hurt it's
taken somewhere in the region of six
years to be able to really regain my
confidence and get myself back yeah I
get it but have you guys heard of lapel
mics no no apparently nobody has I mean
nobody uses them anymore I want to bully
them for the audio quality to my former
self you lose party in the brav your own
ideas RAV when you go through this
oh they're from the guy Richie part of
England
you got a license for that bullying
wait
[Music]
around one out of
experience of workplace bullying and
nearly three-fourths of the case of the
bullying is carried out by a manager
you know what's so funny is like that
this just used to be like your boss
being like a dick because you're doing a
bad job your boss is like what the [ __ ]
are you doing get back to work and now
it's like bullying yeah now it's like uh
what do you mean you can't what do you
mean I'm in trouble for taking a one
hour and a half dump on company time oh
oh I can't poop
waving magnets in front of my nose they
think it's funny in it
unless your boss like is like they're
like yeah my boss head-butted me okay
okay look that's a good point being like
all right you know what I mean that's a
little over the line but if your boss is
being a jerk like let's just work bro it
sucks yeah so bullying to one person may
mean yeah Hey listen Royce I need you to
get that report Into Me by Friday
otherwise look we're gonna have to write
you up stop bullying oh my God no it
literally it's one job you're like it's
your job and they go you're bullying me
you're bullying me right now I'm by the
way the parking looks like the some sort
of human Council rights meeting
Association or whether they have like
that trans chick that was melting down
at that self trackout yes screaming
basically like I'm being raped it's like
you're ma'am this is a self-checkout no
one's even near you
May mean something completely different
to the next person it is quite
subjective and it could be hard to
define or even to recognize it's hard to
Define and recognize that's always good
that's just the whole feel like whatever
your feelings are or real that's what
that is I go yeah it's like literally
can't be Quantified nobody knows what it
is by the way but when you when you if
it's happening then it's happening if
you're religious and you describe God
that way they laugh at you but literally
all their problems are made up and you
can't quantify it either what do you
mean you can't see yeah but what does
she think they're going to walk up to
her and give her wedgies like
it's also but yeah it makes me laugh
that like so it's not quantifiable and
you're just like okay so then can we
move on to things that are quantum like
we could I'm not even saying I'm not
even dismissing your feelings yeah but
can we Circle back to this once you're
able to sort of verbalize what I mean
imagine if they're like you actually
think this is [ __ ] and they're like
okay so did your boss push you in a
locker did he give you a swirly thing
did he call you a slur and you're like
no none of those things but I'm telling
you he was bullying me purple nurples no
okay get out of here no Indian sunburn
no a Native American sunburners Native
of indigenous Sunday indigenous
two-spirit sunburn sunburn
happening what may seem trivial such as
just exceeding someone from the coffee
whenever oh man look at those white
males they don't care about that woman
at all I gotta feel it wait a minute
she's right no she's not she's wait a
minute excluding people from a coffee
run but you know how many jobs I've had
where I mean every single day one or two
people got [ __ ] and it was no it
happened you just weren't around
sometimes like there have been times
I've been at jobs where everyone's busy
and one guys like bing bong bing and but
two people are out on break and like
there's nobody to go hey go ask them but
when there's like a little bit slower
there's people somebody go oh I'll go
ask them and then there's days where
everybody's busy and you go I've had
days where I came in I'm like oh cool
that's cool nobody got you know asked me
if I want a coffee you know and then the
other part and then and then if they
would have offered her coffees with
don't hit on me it's a workplace exactly
I have a boyfriend okay you're like okay
I just was good what do you want from me
running over time that plates are really
oppressive working environment a really
oppressive working requirement as they
both were hit jobs it's got to be one of
the funniest things that has ever
happened at the same time a really
oppressive work environment or as we
used to wait wait they might be working
in Saudi Arabia remotely oh that's a
good point although the one on the right
thick nice okay but isn't it just every
work environment is this impressive work
it's work is the most oppressive thing
of the day that's all he's been you go
in and go to work you get it done and
then you got your freeze your work time
is not supposed to feel like your free
time
I'll told you you have to watch the
Pierce Morgan documentary and then you
could go home
[Laughter]
sometimes people
people disabled with their mental health
and they can never work again
all right we knew this is where this is
going you know it was gonna go I've been
bullied to the point where I need to go
on disability so I can't work we get it
we don't you don't want to work nobody
does do you know if you just disabled
every single safety net right now just
dismantled all of it like a good 60 of
these people would figure it out they'd
figure something out yeah all of a
sudden when there's no like it's it's
one of those things where everybody has
all these self-diagnosed like I don't
know man I can't work I'm just too you
know I'm just too depressed and you're
like you you have it's because you have
that option it's it's not like you know
just nobody there's not a lot of
depression in Iran or [ __ ] in the
Middle East there's not a lot of people
going oh no I'm too depressed today like
they will shoot you in the face people
people in Africa don't have fibromyalgia
exactly
five years removed from people being
like yeah my boss grabbed my ass yeah I
know like that was five years ago that
they would be like yeah he grabbed my
ass and now they're like it's
unquantifiable but it's bullying five
years ago Matt Mad Men was the most
popular show on TV and everybody loved
the ass Grabbers on the show just to
tell you where we were five years ago
and now it's like
um it's a microaggression because he
didn't ask me if I wanted a caramel frop
frap frap uh from The Coffee Bean
sadly we have lots of clients who who
suffer with Suicidal Thoughts oh but
dude listen man I work at this [ __ ] I
might be a boss but I work at this
[ __ ] just like you do I have like
five bosses above me I can't be worried
if you're suicidal I can't all right
maybe she's talking about Foxconn though
I need to take a person where she goes
they don't like the Nets
suicide Nets she's like I need to take a
personal day for self-care and you're
like yeah listen I've been working 60
hours a week and I'm getting a divorce
so I'm about to lose my kids so how
about you tighten up and get the goddamn
report to me please I can take a
personal day
sometimes people will speak up and say
that something is bullying when actually
they're really just being a massive
[ __ ] and then we stop bullying them and
we go I'll show you what bullion is made
getting Locker brav you go you [ __ ]
what mate
guy Rich England's my favorite thing it
is the best English yeah
performance issue assuming it's a
reasonable request from your manager
then that is not workplace bullying but
for the most disagree oh I think okay
good point so wait let's say look
hypothetical here there's nobody
specifically but let's say I'm sort of
shop teacher with humongous breasts huge
bibs and somebody walks up and they go
hey nice teeth nice tits teach is that
workplace harassment
if the principal does it yes yes okay
okay good good good
depends children do it it's just mission
accomplished for them
the manager then that is not workplace
bullying but for the most part if
somebody feels as though they're being
bullied
oh that's the most important thing
facts don't care about your feelings
what these should have mandatory Ben
Shapiro and all these all of them all of
them a button that you could press it
just doesn't print your video saying
something Shapiro yeah
what does bullying feel like it's fun Oh
you mean being bullied I wouldn't know
what that feels so [ __ ]
generally on the business and I'm
generally not on the business end of The
Bullying I'm usually you know it feels
great it makes me feel better because
they feel worse why what's the issue
here I guys I think we're the wrong
audience for this video yeah I don't
understand I have I'm emotionally
immature and I feel badly about myself
and when I make others feel worse about
themselves that lifts me up now give me
your lunch money
[ __ ] nerd give me a lunch money Packy
punch him in the stomach in the break
room you're like sir you can't act like
this now that's real bullying
edl salt
if you're not white get out actually you
know hold on if no one's ever said that
to you bro that's Latino's girl yeah at
work they said that they go hey if
you're not this is a whites only meeting
no but that's what do you work for Dr
David Duke like what is this so let me
get this straight they gave all the
black people a day off and you're
complaining yeah that's the thing too
it's like because they have the opposite
of that other companies we go like all
the non-white people go home yeah
because you have it too hard but they
just said it the wrong way I know you're
not like get out
okay excuse me
get out I mean like you can go home and
it's not like man our boss really has to
work on his communication skills guys
guys because of colonization Johnson and
Johnson is doing a no blacks Friday wait
what it's the [ __ ] Vince McMahon clip
if you're not Caucasian well please
he literally says he said that on
television oh
[ __ ]
you know what I mean like I understand
you get on a plane sometimes doesn't
work for Al Qaeda like I understand
something maybe you get on a plane
sometimes you would have funny hair
thing you guys like to wear and I
understand it's a Mets fitted hat yeah
whatever little whatever and I'm sure
people might look at you strangely
talking your little you know pigeon
language into your [ __ ] flip phone
people get nervous okay it's possible he
works at TSA
but sir I doubt anybody at your job
that's known you for three years is like
that guy over there by the way [ __ ]
you mean Steve he's been infiltrating
this place for three what are you
kidding me we went to Bacon Fest
together what are you talking about like
maybe in 2002 he would be like you'd be
like yeah I could see how this is that's
what happened up now but now now when
two Spirits at the top of the list
nobody bro listen unless you're like
some sort of like
I don't know trans Muslim something or
other nobody that's the thing like
that's the thing that's hot right now it
is that's the thing I laugh about a lot
is like they they still think that
everyone's mindset is like right after 9
11 but yeah exactly nobody we've all
just binge watched 24 and yeah
nobody cares anymore no one's afraid of
Muslims anymore what is he talking about
that doesn't happen anymore
um terrorist or what's he got in his
back
proud to be who I am okay then why are
you [ __ ] can I ask you something sir
then why are you spiraling about it no
for real why are you the one that's so
goddamn insecure that you feel as a man
bullied at an office job yeah and also
he's a freelance photographer so he
doesn't work it or not I am very proud
of who I am but I guess like myself
every day to thinking all of my
co-workers this guy I'm a terrorist
because I am [ __ ] crazy but I'm so
proud of myself
workers he's a freelance photographer
all right well okay so you got a
Pakistani guys out here taking [ __ ]
high quality photographs of military
bases and [ __ ] people are gonna come
talk to you for a minute
what if it's John he specifically takes
photos of military I'm just interested
in aviation okay well we got to talk if
he brings his prayer rug with him oh no
oh you gotta come with us Smite listen
here Bravo I told you can't do that bro
you're no longer the top protected
classmate all you two spirit mate
and experiences you
license for that camera oh
we're proud that you're not praying I
still get accepted like everyone else
you know not be judged and due to
collect you to hire anything just go to
work and just have a peaceful day at
work I witnessed people in positions of
power of just yelling at co-workers in
front of other people demeaning them
making sense right quick sexual comments
those things still don't act like hate
this those things don't happen
um
see here oh God so lean and me made a
Photoshop
they did the office space picture all
right remember it's black free Friday so
if you're 1 16th African-American
minimum you get to go home that's that's
to see where he goes ask yourself what
can you do for the company and
somebody's like I have an idea hear me
out hear me out I have an idea
oh [ __ ] all right man we've come to the
end of this show what do you care
Darnell you don't like casual Fridays
anyway you don't have any Hawaiian
shirts
remember on black free Friday is also
casual racism Friday it's weird
um when the black people come in on
Casual Friday you're like I didn't mean
that casual Jesus Christ
you're dressed for a video shoot they
Quorum is my cousin guys thank you so
much you're such an ass
well played sir uh bro